fifty-two seconds of logos is not a
second goes by when I'm not thinking of
you somewhere
narration tells us things we could
figure out through silent reflection
movie could have started with this scene
chooses instead to subject us to four
and a half minutes of Otway writing and
reading a letter Liam Neeson isn't
killing anyone in this scene
coincidental noise prevents a suicide
cliche Holloway yeah so uh glass
critters really behinds are some of that
sniper's shit what's the biggest piece
of game you take him down like a Cody
huh you know I saw that documentary that
asshole did overly talkative annoying
airplane seat neighbor is overly
talkative awesome curtain closing that
signals the passage of time is actually
awesomely confusing we interrupt this
terrence malick wolf killing movie to
bring you inception we interrupt loss to
bring you even more Inception someone
needs to explain this how to survive a
terrible plane crash technique that only
movie characters seem to know go
shokran others but I needed to start out
with hoping those two statements are
conflicting you're gonna die that's
what's happening Liam Neeson doesn't
have any bedside manner in this scene
howling winds die down for a few moments
out of respect for the dying man I
really wish we'd gotten to know this guy
beforehand so that his 3-minute death
scene didn't seem excessive oh there's
the howling wind again maybe I'll turn
into a Bulls fan huh huh
wait that's not real right I know we're
going for annoying stupid guy number
three here with this character but
really no man would like rabies or
whatever I didn't think the motherfuck
who's gonna grow claws and teeth ain't
yes you did
look I'm not a proponent of looting in
general but honestly this cash is gonna
do no one any good buried out here in
the snow forever that's perfectly good
money hell even if you only think of it
as paper which burns and you use it for
kindling it's still more useful to take
it then leave it behind as some kind of
memorial no one will ever see I'm gonna
start reading this none of you in the
next five seconds and you're gonna
swallow a lot of blood
Oh Bell Tolls holy shit I've got to
remove one soon for that line right
there
I'm sure dead bodies all over man want
to make sure you know where that meat
came from oh it's like that movie where
they start taking chunks of frozen that
guy your funniest the movie alive
becomes a comedy when you find yourself
in that exact situation don't move in
Hollywood every bloodthirsty animal can
be defeated by playing statue somehow on
Eddie wolf killing Otway doesn't wake up
during all this I'm no Alaska expert but
if it's blowing like this in a vast
wilderness of snow for even a little bit
shouldn't everything be drifted over by
now or at least starting to drift over
it's been like 24 hours oh now it's
starting to drift you collect all the
wallets oh by your loss nope you
shouldn't have heard anyone say anything
because no one could even hear wolves
tearing a man to pieces outside when
they were in the plane she can act on
the wallets for the families wait what
this is a complete waste of time energy
and stamina
none of which they have very much up
also on the previous night Otway said
they needed to move the bodies out of
here but there are still dead bodies all
over the place near the wreckage
wait what you can't find some way to use
that thing not even as a blunt
instrument how did the note which would
scrumpet up into a ball and stuffed into
the seat pouch before the crash end up
with a coffee stain on it and that stain
is only in the center of the paper I
feel like we should say something I mean
all these bodies oh my god remember the
wolves huntin Otway tosses shotgun
shells directly over raging fire No Mas
that's racist
everyone is conveniently looking down
when the wolf approaches and gets close
enough to grab this guy without being
seen
I know you're making bang sticks but
geez you haven't gotten paranoid enough
yet to be constantly scanning the
horizon ideas I think you got him they
all enjoy a good laugh before bothering
to check if Diaz's wounds are serious
movie lingers on Wolfe beheading shot
for roughly 50 seconds too long Diaz
went through all the gory disgusting
beheading no way to toss the head a
measly 15 feet duck hook to the left
this guy wakes up with a wolf-like snarl
to startle people
say was a good one it's an idea I didn't
say it was a good one cliche even
supposing Diaz could catch this tether
doesn't he do the work of three men here
by someone stopping a body in freefall
wouldn't he just fall right over the
cliff you know with the momentum and
whatnot right how those two statements
are conflicted violation of the 180
degree rule makes this falling scene
confusing it looks like he's falling
toward the trees in this shot but it
looks like he's falling toward the cliff
in the shot
it sure is kind of the wolves to keep
leaving everyone's wallets behind after
they kill these idiots so they can keep
collecting them first names jobs why do
the Wolves keep hanging back during
these soft emotional conversations is it
out of respect where are you going that
night at the bar you had your rifle
Henrik must have been on his shift is
Sherlock Holmes that night figuring the
guy at the bar who just happened to have
his rifle was thinking of killing
himself alright with your rifle also why
is it even a little bit suspicious to
see the plants a sniper walk out of the
bar with his rifle he walked in with it
right I guarantee as a look he had I've
only seen it one other time at last
night in town guy an bar somehow decodes
the I'm gonna die face and remembered it
later there's nothing Liam Neeson
doesn't answer Liam Neeson's prayers in
this scene the last time we saw this
letter it was stained with coffee or
something Wolff understands that this is
a battle where his opponent should be
able to prepare weapons and fit before
he goes in for the attack out land the
wolf fought each other during the
credits who won fuck you that's who also
I guess if you believe out we won this
battle you're supposed to believe the
other wolves just sat back and said this
dude knows how to party one of us one of
us also either you have a cliffhanger
ending or you don't or you just do an
end credits scene and have it both ways
it's a king down
the direwolf is the sigil of your house
they're meant to have them
hey did you just take his wallet you
just took that guy's wallet I think he
took your wallet it's like a bang stick
this is my boomstick once more into the
fray
it's the last good fight I'll ever know
oh well your first beat I'm not gonna
die yesterday
I'm gonna kill the man